qu'on informe les les adolescents
notamment sur la sexualité les les
conséquences parfois des instrueux que
ça peut avoir mais c'est très bien mais
qu'on le fasse à l'école ça qu'on
distribue des petits manuels à l'école
au début de l'année voilà chacun le lit
que ce soit la vie que ce soit figé
comme ça qui est des enfants qui
demandent à leurs parents ça veut dire
quoi la pénétration etc
ça me gênerait terriblement mais quand
même mes enfants ne me demande ça ils
ont 30 ans maintenant
personne n'oblige les parents à
expliquer s'ils n'ont pas envie de le
faire des très jeunes enfants d'ailleurs
ne seront même pas lire ils vont pas
faire nécessairement attention
7-8 ans et sablir d'accord mais c'est
pas lire ça ça va pas les traumatiser
à leurs parents c'est très gênant je
voudrais quand même juste rappeler la
raison pour laquelle parce que c'est ça
qui est c'est ça qui est important
s'informer dialoguer pour limiter les
situations pouvant dégrader la santé
sexuelle donc en fait c'est pour leur
avenir aussi
les jeunes vont commencer à avoir des
relations un enfant de 7 ans qui lit ça
c'est très gênant bah si 7 ans si c'est
tant bien sûr voter s'il vous plaît
parce que c'était le pénétration
de la sexualité comme ça qu'il le fasse
bien bravo même moi je suis choqué alors
il y en a même un problème de
l'adolescence et même les adultes ça
peut les mettre pas là je suis désolé
les enfants de 7000 c'est le ça changera
pas du tout
sauf que si ça change juste un truc ça
sert juste un truc à ce que des enfants
de 7-8 ans se posent des questions qui
se serait jamais posé avant Daniel
chérie
évidemment mais non mais c'était très
facile de mettre la même campagne avec
si vous avez des questions bien sûr si
ça vous pouvez poser question
sexualité.fr excuse-moi c'est encore de
la provocation j'en ai marre de la
journée pas grandir nos enfants
tranquilles mais on s'agit de partout
excusez-moi et là c'est le service
excusez-moi on a eu des débats où les
choses
cette campagne est parfaite elle est
provocatrice inutilement
ça ne fera pas un truc de plus si on a
envie d'avoir des des si on a envie
d'avoir des réponses question
sexualité.fr
c'est quoi la meilleure contraception
pour moi ça te choque mais
je n'ai pas
de direction des érections vous êtes
vous mettez pas
la pénétration
ça fait mal c'est pas possible de lire
ça c'est très gênant excuse-moi
j'ai un abribus République française en
haut à gauche et la pénétration je suis
désolé je n'aime pas cette société
Jean-Marie ça étonne tout le monde que
t'aimais oui ça c'est sûr
[Musique]
mais ça nous viendrait pas à l'idée ma
femme et moi même de sortir un gros mot
ou un truc comme ça et moi je devrais
taper sur les sur les doigts
tous les soirs il y a longtemps donc les
enfants apprennent les choses par contre
de mettre ça dans un abribus je suis
choqué exactement
mais il y avait d'autres manières de
faire je ne comprends pas je ne
comprends pas l'intérêt de mettre ces
mots chocs pénétration érection qui vont
encore une fois choper les enfants les
interpellés sur des sujets auxquels ils
ne devrait pas avoir accès mais la
sexualité
mais non c'est intime tu ne confondues
s'il te plaît merci Guillaume on ne
confronte pas les enfants à la sexualité
il y a un âge pour tout la sexualité
intime c'est sacré et on ne met pas ça
dans le dans l'espace public comme ça
devant des enfants pour les enfants
j'ai pris un ou deux noms comme ça
des mineurs en protection de la jeunesse
nous avons Jean-Marie
parce que il s'automutile parce qu'ils
se suicide donc c'est très très utile
alors et vous pensez vraiment que un
petit enfant qui va lire ça ou voilà il
va passer bon il va l'aimer bien sûr
un dépravé sexuel je pensais vraiment
qui va devenir un déséquilibré
attends prends ton élan
[Rires]
toute seule tu as dit c'est un message à
diffusion des adolescents alors pourquoi
tu le mets dans les chutes bus et tout
le monde le voit
dans les lycées dans les collèges elle a
vu le dit oui c'est vrai que c'est un
vrai sujet
c'est inadmissible que des enfants de 6
ans de 7 ans c'est bon c'est bon non
mais fermer ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
il y a des cons il y a aussi des
campagnes télé pour cette opération par
exemple
je vais prendre combien d'années de
prison
moi je comprends les gens qui soient
choqués qui sont choqués les mecs tu
peux pas avoir des enfants de 6 ans de 7
ans de 5 ans de 8 ans qui regarde ça
c'est inadmissible je suis désolé
excusez-moi
on peut faire autrement voilà
ça t'es imposé
donc ça tu peux tu comprends pas le
principe de la télé ma chérie là c'est
là c'est imposé quand tu es sur toutes
les chaînes tu es imposé maman et on dit
c'est pas pour toi c'est pour l'écran
les défenseurs de la connerie je vous
connaissez les yeux des enfants les
enfants
ce genre de message qui vous a donné la
parole ben Jean-Michel
certainement pas on dirait une connerie
pareil
[Applaudissements]
pour une connerie
la télé une mère avec maman avec son
enfant ne va peut-être pas justement
parce qu'elle va avoir Bigard ou moi en
revanche là maintenant j'ai raté
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la maman elle dit c'est pas pour toi
c'est pour les grands on en parleurs
le soir tu l'allume ou tu l'allumes pas
tu dis non c'est pas pour toi
tu parles de là-bas
mais vous qui êtes le champion des
jeunes qui nous regardent il faut savoir
que 16% des femmes de 18 à 69 ans ont eu
des rapports sexuels douloureux
que ce soit lui déjà je sais pas qui
vous êtes toujours
tais-toi tais-toi tais-toi parce que là
tu dis un truc d'une pitié non je vous
donne des chiffres non mais tais-toi 2
minutes que tu me fatigues là et je
comprends les gens qui me disent que tu
es fatigué
tu fatigues tout le monde tu dis d'une
chose mais tu ne bêtises Gilles comment
tu peux être aussi bête excuse-moi je
t'aime beaucoup
tu es d'une bêtise excuse-moi mon chéri
mais tu es là tu dis des trucs d'une
bêtise écoute moi on a on a pas
critiquer
bête ou quoi qu'il fasse une campagne
c'est très bien oui mais arrête ta voix
elle a insupportable on dirait que on
dirait que c'est la lame de ma voiture
j'en peux plus je dois te sortir à
chaque fois donc je vous explique c'est
pas et on a pas que pratiquer la
campagne il critique pas la campagne ici
et le fait qu'il fasse
mais ce qu'on critique c'est les
méthodes de la campagne et que ils ont
voulu frapper fort ils ont été trop loin
à un moment il y a un curseur à mettre
et que là ils sont allés trop loin dans
leur curseur et que je vais vous dire
c'est extrêmement choquant et je vais
vous dire j'ai vu énormément de messages
de parents qui m'ont écrit qui m'ont dit
Cyril c'est inadmissible est-ce que vous
allez parler de ça moi j'ai un garçon de
6 ans et un fils de 5 ans j'ai une
petite scale de 7 ans qui s'ablir qui
savait écrire qui voit ça et je me
balade avec eux j'ai honte de prendre le
bus je sais pas quoi faire je suis à
l'arrêt je suis à l'arrêt de bus je sais
pas où regarder c'est bon je sais pas où
regarder je sais pas quoi leur dire donc
c'est c'est le problème
inscrivez cette situation dans la vraie
vie imaginez que vos parents quand vous
aviez 6 ans vous parlent d'érection et
de pénétration
on confronte des enfants à de la
sexualité frontale et trash ce n'est pas
là il y a un âge surtout
c'est la tranche d'âge 5 ans 8 ans
exactement Jean-Michel et Géraldine
puisque c'est très bien de faire passer
des messages mettons aussi des images à
ce moment-là mettons des images bah à
l'enregistre au bout du principe si les
Moon suffisent pas toujours mettons des
images pour que mes enfants comprennent
bien ah bah voilà là tu vois mais quand
on te dit ça
prend ton élan la prochaine fois
c'est justement j'ai plein enfin j'ai
des enfants je leur ai des enfants ils
ont 45 ans 45 ans ils ont ils ont
d'abord ils avaient été petits et ils
ont été petit endroit bah oui ils ont
entre 13 et 22 ans là ce sont des mots
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire sinon ça veut
dire qu'en fait la sexualité c'est tabou
exactement en parler les mots donc
pour moi chez moi avec mes enfants c'est
un langage que moi la sexualité n'est
aucun mais tu fais ce que tu veux oui je
fais ce que tu veux mais tu mets pas tu
jettes pas ça non tu jettes pas ça aux
yeux des gens qui ont rien demandé moi
si mon enfant lit ce truc là et me
demande ce que c'est que la pénétration
je vais lui expliquer si la la avec des
mots qui sont tout le monde
c'est ton problème
pénétration c'est où
Marie Bigard
c'est bon voilà c'est vrai c'est pas
gênant
le respect que c'est un choix
d'éducation mais c'est un choix chez toi
là c'est un choix en rien
non mais excuse-moi Sophie fais passer
des tests avant mais nous embête pas
pardonnez-moi mais je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec toi Daniel parce que le
contement
la contraception c'est quelque chose
c'est un problème de santé
il déplace le débat bah oui bien sûr
Daniel tu as tout à fait raison s'il
vous plaît il déplace le débat et ils
sont non mais ils sont d'une
malhonnêteté et c'est horrible Daniel tu
me comprends chérie exactement tu ne
malhonnêteté et elle ne dit pas Daniel
qui ne faut pas faire la campagne elle
dit qu'elle est mal faite et qu'elle est
choquante et vous les enfants ont
bazarine dans les lycées
elle va voir tes amis à l'Assemblée
nationale et arrêtez monsieur
évidemment évidemment c'est pas tabou et
quand tes enfants
quand tes enfants te posent des
questions sur leur sexualité tu dois
leur répondre évidemment sauf que là
sauf que là tu leur poses des questions
qui se posaient pas qui leur impose des
messages
arrêtez d'abord de penser que les
enfants ne savaient rien à la maîtresse
d'école qui arrive là
mais il y a des études qui ont montré
que dès l'âge de 9 ans entre 9 ans et 11
ans les enfants ont déjà été exploités
il faut bien répondre à ces questions
par ailleurs c'est des schématiques que
les enfants que que auquel il faut
répondre auprès des enfants et les
petits quand ils sont vraiment petits
d'abord à mon avis ça leur vient pas à
l'esprit posé la question mais si quand
bien sûr
il poserait la question tu leur réponds
avec des mots d'enfants alors tu vas
remercier trop petit
on va voir le résultat du sondage voilà
merci
bravo bravo
[Applaudissements]
il faut parfois tout le contraire donc
ne dis pas de bêtises mon chéri je leur
ai dit de regarder ses news à l'époque
ils n'ont pas regardé donc arrête c'est
bon le truc de la pénétration qui gêne
non c'est gênant Géraldine le truc
érection pénétration et pourquoi les
Chéries je voudrais bien
les sondages regarde la pilule je fais
quoi ça oui ça va ok
78,5
moi je suis moi la pilule remettez les
trucs voilà la pilule c'est pas gênant
voilà la pénétration me fait mal oui
comment savoir si elle a toujours envie
qu'on voilà ça ça peut avoir
ça ça peut être ça c'est bien ça passe
moi c'est j'ai des pannes directions que
faire non excusez-moi ça c'est pas
excusez-moi
que en gros c'était une manœuvre un peu
secret
excuse-moi
il y a une espèce de mouvance qui fait
que
on va faire parler des questions qui ne
se serait jamais rapporté par exemple si
c'était vraiment une campagne de
prévention
quelqu'un te donne un bonbon ne le suis
pas moi c'était ça qu'on me disait je
veux dire
oh tais-toi tais-toi tais-toi Hugo
Daniel Bravo chérie juste un truc les
chéris moi j'étais avec un pote alors
dans la lol il a dit exactement ce qu'il
a dit il m'a dit on essaie on fait on se
fait poser des et on fait poser des
questions aux enfants on leur fait poser
se poser des questions et qui ne se
posaient pas et qui n'ont pas envie de
se poser et forcément et ça ça y
contribue c'est des trucs c'est des
questions je suis désolé les enfants
faut les laisser grandir alors là je
vais vous dire ils ont toujours grandi
alors il faut les laisser découvrir en
eux-mêmes arrêtez de vouloir forcer les
enfants à découvrir des choses trop tôt
alors apprendre trop tôt des choses je
suis désolé et je vois le sondage là et
Gilles Verdez s'il te plaît arrête avec
tes conneries 78 78
je repose une campagne de
sensibilisation diffusée sur certains
parents faut-il la retirer oui à 78,7 %
et sachez qu'il y a eu énormément de
vote on va on a pas 78 % de fous alors
bien sûr les 21 %, c'est pas des fous
non plus c'est peut-être des personnes
qui sont qui sont comme des Sophie Coss
comme dit Géraldine Valérie bénigne où
on veut expliquer je pense que la
plupart des gens aujourd'hui ils sont
non marre de cette société où les
enfants on les laisse pas grandir je
vous le dis c'est insupportable il se
pose des questions qui ne se posaient
pas avant à des âges
s'il vous plaît merci